cool cool all right
all right so lima you're back yes i am
welcome back
um so last time
you were here you spoke about how we're
going to do a a scholarship is that what
you're calling it
for somebody that has appeared on my
channel yes and we talked long and hard
about who it could be and there's lots
of people that are good
candidates and i also asked for comments
from your viewers
of um who they wanted right right
because the funding
is coming from the viewers we want to
listen to them
and we had an overwhelming response
for one special person yeah and i also
told you like
it depends on how big a challenge you
want yeah and there's some people that
are that are
good for that would be perfect for this
yeah but they would probably be
easier yeah easier to deal with
yes and who you know who's the hardest
amanda is the most difficult case yeah
so
so you chose amanda yes i chose amanda
which i think is very brave of you thank
you
and i chose amanda with you specifically
because
you and i both discussed this and
not only does amanda have a lot of
people praying for her and a lot of
people that
really want to see her get better but
amanda is the poster child of an
impossible case
so when people look at amanda i think
it's really
easy to think the word hopeless and when
i look at amanda i see someone that's
trapped and lost and i think that
if we can use amanda as a template for
what care should be and that we can save
amanda's life
then everyone can can see amanda as
you know a template for hope so
you know so there is i don't believe in
an impossible case
but i don't think that there's a better
candidate than amanda and so
we plan to document how we're helping
amanda
because one of the most challenging
things about her
is that she does not want to go to
treatment she doesn't want help
and there's a it's when it comes to
addiction
when it comes to mental illness a lot of
times
people don't want to get better they
don't want the help not sometimes
90 percent of the time yeah they might
say it here in
an interview yeah you catch them after
the interview and say hey would you like
to do this that or the other
yeah and then they might even actually
go into treatment
for a day or two and then they leave and
it's really really tough
so we're going to be documenting exactly
how we're getting amanda into treatment
how we're putting her into these
programs
and the reason for that is because i
think that amanda when she gets better
that she's going to be an inspiration
for a lot of people because
when she she can use her story
as a way to demonstrate for others how
to get better
and what that's going to be is it's
going to give her purpose in her life
so i think that it couldn't be better
and it's also
there's a lot of things that have taken
me a while to learn with my family
so instead of everyone having to fail
and learn and fail and learn
then why not just share this information
just you know put it out there yeah your
experience with your sisters i think
really kind of helps you deal with
people like amanda yes
absolutely and then something else has
happened with amanda that
kind of helped right yes um she ended up
in jail
exactly and that's actually the best
thing that could have happened
um do you want me to go into how this
happened
the truth is the truth okay so i've had
i have permission to state this from the
family
um and so basically amanda had
attacked her father with a pipe and
he reached out to mark and he asked mark
what he should do and mark suggested
calling the police on amanda
which was the best thing he could have
possibly done
as a family member it's really hard to
call 9-1-1
and it feels like a betrayal to that
person
but at the same time amanda's in a safe
place now where she can't use drugs
correct
she can't use crack she can't hurt
herself
and she's being fed and clothed
and the reason that this is so
significant is the way that you get
somebody that doesn't want to get help
into treatment
is through something called an lps
conservatorship
and that's what we're using for amanda
what that entails
is that it's a very difficult process
because you don't want to be dating
someone and then they get mad at you
and then all of a sudden you're being
forced to go to
a you know mental health facility
so they make it challenging because they
want to make sure it's not abused so
essentially you have to prove
two things and it's easier if it's a
family member so amanda's father is
working really really hard
night and day to make this happen with
me
so you need to prove that the person is
gravely disabled
number one and that the second thing is
that
they have a severe mental illness so
amanda has actually been to seven
treatment centers
nothing's worked for her she's relapsed
every time she's kind of given up on
treatment
and you know of course they're all
very short-term stays and then the
second factor
so she's already been diagnosed her
current diagnosis
is schizophrenic and bipolar and
we are going to review that diagnosis
with our team and a team of specialists
see if there's any under other
underlining issues or if anything is a
misdiagnosis
the second factor that we have to prove
and we've been working on doing this
is she has to check off one of three
things but fortunately amanda checks off
all three
so it's shelter food and clothing
and so that's what grave gravely
disabled means is that the person
cannot provide shelter food or clothing
for themselves so again it only has to
be one of these three
and so essentially by shelter
the person doesn't have a safe place to
live by
food the person has lost a significant
amount of weight
that could be a health risk and by
clothing it could be that the person
will not change their clothes for a long
period of time
so bacteria build up can also cause a
health risk to that person
or that the person takes off their
clothing at inappropriate times
which could be a health risk because of
the weather if it's very cold if it's
very hard i can't tell you how many
times i've seen amanda walking down the
street
no shoes no socks no pants just just a
tank top
yeah and nothing else i'll buy her pants
and shoes and she'll just walk away yes
just leave them on the sidewalk so um
basically checks off every box right and
and
and the only way that you can get it um
an lps conservatorship put through
is if the person isn't holding and so
the person must be in holding in either
a jail
or a psychiatric hospital so let's say
you walk in on your family member and
they're trying to hurt themselves
you can call for a 5150 and
that person would be put on a 72 hour
hold
for a suicide watch and in that time
frame
if you have the paperwork already put
together
you have to act very quickly in only
three days
um you can work with the um with a
patient's doctor and then of course for
the jail factor if someone is attacking
you or trying
to hurt you you can call 9-1-1 and they
would be taken to a jail
but at the same time because they have a
mental illness they have certain
medications they're supposed to take
there's a doctor that's involved and so
when you have that paperwork ready to go
you would contact the person's defender
and you would also contact
the doctor of of the patient and so by
working with the health care provider
having the document already filled out
and ready to go
you can have that that doctor it's only
a one-page document because
it needs to be proven very simply but by
having that
page filled out ready to go if the
doctor
recommends that the conservatorship
goes through then you have one year of
treatment that you can actually force on
the patient and um
it's really important for people to
understand
that getting raped on skid row being
homeless
having a random person and jacked heroin
into your arm
you know having a threat of disease
to anyone else that would be rock bottom
and that would be an opportunity
to completely change your life and say i
want to do something different this is
not my life
to someone that has been in severe
trauma
and has become disabled by their traumas
just completely crippled
that this isn't this the ability for
them to do whatever they want which is
essentially to kill themselves be
self-destructive
is not a rock bottom for them so they'll
continue to do it until they die
and what is rock bottom
is that taking away that control
so what we're working on is having two
options for amanda when the lps
conservatorship goes through
she's gonna have either an actual
treatment center where they're going to
work
with her they're going to provide care
they're going to do the therapies
and she's going to she's going to have
that for a year if she leaves if she
walks out
her only other option is a psychiatric
hospital and basically
they sedate you they give you
medications and there's nothing to do
there except to sleep
and watch tv and walk in circles so
you're either going to be held in a
psych ward or you're going to be
you know given the opportunity to go to
a beautiful treatment center
where you have a team of people working
with you to help you get better
and if you choose to leave again back to
the psych ward and it's just going to be
a ping pong
between psych ward and treatment and
possibility of her
of amanda escaping and running back to
where she likes to be
on the street um you can't escape an
inpatient facility
so it's pretty much like you're under
lockdown
and a residential treatment center
you can walk out of it's a lot of these
facilities
can be the ones that we're going to be
sending to amanda to
are going to look like you know
beautiful homes
that it's not a clinical
it doesn't look clinical at all it's
just a beautiful home it feels like
you're you're not in a hospital setting
and they take you out on outings and
they help you
um merge into the real world
while practicing these different skills
so any facility that amanda is going to
be going to through our scholarship
program
is going to be an aura treatment center
which means that
it's a clinic that is partnering up with
us to use our technology
and so just a quick recap of what that
technology is
is it's health detection so we do
we have a computer microphone
we analyze voice stress cravings
we use technology to really figure out
additional data streams to help the
doctor
treat the patient and then there's also
a mobile app
that does telehealth and also the
you know stress analysis mood analysis
voice analysis and all of that
so it's just a mobile version of the
technology um
and so essentially with that
amanda's going to have door-to-door care
so she's going to have a year of
treatment if she chooses to walk out
because
like i said residential treatment
centers are
completely optional nobody's being
forced to go you can leave at any time
so they're not going to restrain her and
make her stay if she leaves
with the lps conservatorship we will
have her escorted back to a psychiatric
hospital
where she'll be held until she changes
her mind and wants to go to treatment
and so that's basically
her rock bottom when she realizes i
can't just go
run wild and free on the streets i have
to change something or i'm going to keep
bouncing back and forth
if something doesn't work in a year you
can actually
take that lps conservatorship and have
it renewed
for a following year showing that you
have the support
so if we're able to raise the funds
through the gofundme campaign
to pay for amanda's treatment for a year
um
then essentially we'll be able to cover
all of her medical expenses
and those are those are significant
right yes
so typically it costs well over 300
000 but the treatment centers that i
work with are willing to discount the
rates
and so we're also right now we've had
some very generous donations
from i think about 20 supporters so i'm
very grateful
and we're using the funds that we have
to get amanda health insurance she
doesn't have that
so health insurance will pay for 30 days
of treatment
at a treatment center so that's going to
help us
offset some of the costs and also you
know detox and hospitalizations and
medications
on the health insurance will also help
there so we're doing something against
amanda's will yes but her will is to
kill herself
exactly her will is complete
self-destruction and also
she's not in a proper state of mind to
make those decisions for herself because
she's unable to take care of herself
and everybody just wants to see her get
better yeah no her dad and i have been
trying to get the police to do a 5150 on
her forever but
they they explained that that's just not
going to happen especially with kovid
going on but even
even if covet wasn't happening no while
they're they're
um they're way over packed
so mental health is a massive
issue for the country but since covet is
hit you know
addiction is a disease of isolation and
so is depression
so all of a sudden you're having people
mandated to quarantine
and it's um
you know suicide rates are spiking a lot
of people are um
struggling with with what they're
dealing with and
um the typica the normal standards of
telehealth just don't cut it
because when it comes to mental illness
i can see you
and i can be fine and i can be smiling
and genuinely feel okay
and then two hours later i just want to
die
something happened i'm stuck on a
thought and i just can't let go of it
so um so with our with our telehealth
application we're working on scaling
that as well so we are working with our
with our team to scale that
and and bring it outside of just the
treatment centers we work with
so that it's accessible one of the
things i
do want to address is i had quite a few
comments so
i am working on responding to like i
said
at least 10 comments a day because
everybody's feedback
is really important to me and one of the
most
reoccurring comments that i saw was why
do
i charge so much for my technology and
so
essentially we don't
we at this moment are giving the
technology to these facilities at no
cost
so we're giving it to them for research
purposes and we're documenting
the cases and
these facilities are charging on average
45 000
per month per patient so what we want to
do is we want to make our technology
available to everybody so we have a
petition
to petitions that i've started and what
those two petitions are
is we're going to use amanda as a case
study
and we're going to document exactly how
we're helping her get treatment and with
the funds
that are being raised from the viewers
the ability to pay for
for an entire year of care for her we're
going to demonstrate
that you know we're able to reduce the
relapse she's actually able to get
better and heal
and in the long term it's
it's going to save insurance companies
money if they actually
treat mental illness like physical
illness and do long-term care for it
honestly mental illness is a physical
problem because
there's something wrong with your brain
right
and then the second the second thing
that that we're doing with these
petitions is proposing a new
administration policy
and so what that looks like is we want
to start
mandating tools like aura but it doesn't
have to be
aura it can be anybody because we
welcome
other people getting involved in this
industry and innovating
and contributing so it would be
tools so we want to we want to promote
new administration policies in insurance
and government
to mandate some sort of
tools to track patient progress and also
health detection so that we're not just
relying on how are you feeling
and so if we're able to get a hundred
thousand signatures
in 30 days on we the people.gov
we will be able to we will be guaranteed
a response from the white house
so that would be really amazing and then
the second thing is
on the change.org petition we're going
to be taking that to insurance companies
so that
everybody that's watching will also be
able to benefit
from a program similar to what we're
doing for amanda
it's amazing yeah um i commend you on
your
courage thank you because it'll be so
easy to pick somebody who's an easier
case yeah absolutely you chose the most
difficult one you could find
yes because i like i said i don't
believe in an
impossible case and i think that anyone
that's looking at themselves and
thinking that they're hopeless
when they watch amanda get better
they're gonna you know sign up and
and they're gonna really put the effort
in
yeah and then i do have one last thing
to add is
if anybody does want a template of the
lps conservatorship
or detailed information on how to put
that
document through for their loved one
then you can direct message me on
instagram at lima from ora
and i'll send you a link to the template
and outline
excellent lastly i just want to
address one more thing that i read in
the comments
and that was the gofundme campaign so i
just want to really clearly state
that the funds raised from the gofundme
campaign are going directly to a company
who's our fiscal sponsor
for jibs the nonprofit and it's
giving.org
giving collects all of the money so mark
and i never actually have access to the
funds
and giving will pay the hospitals and
clinics directly on amanda's behalf
so for every 250 000 raised we're going
to bring in
another person from the interviews and
if everyone donates
10 dollars to the campaign everyone
that's watching
we can help everyone on the channel and
even some of the viewers
so our goal is to make the fund big
enough so that
we can cover the expenses for anyone
that applies and start an application
process for it
but at this time we're going to use the
petitions to really drive insurance
companies in the government to change
the industry
very exciting cool will i be able to do
like updates with amanda
absolutely so we're going to be doing
updates with amanda
and i not that i haven't done enough
already
we're going to be doing really positive
updates with amanda we're going to be
documenting step by step exactly how
you know she's she's benefiting in
exactly the path that we're taking with
her treatment
so that other people can can take that
model and apply it to their situations
and i just met my husband and i just had
dinner with
amanda's father on friday and
so amanda's father was a veteran and
amanda is one of four children
so her three siblings are actually doing
very well
and when amanda was younger she aspired
to be a newscaster
and so when she was in college she was
actually chasing that dream
and so i actually found it very
interesting that
in college suddenly she she began to get
very paranoid
and she had reached out to her dad and
told him
somebody's watching me i think they're
surveilling me and
larry didn't know how to spot anything
you know any mental illness or anything
weird
so he was concerned for his daughter so
he changed her phone
he changed her number he was trying to
help her get
you know be safe he didn't know what was
going on and so
um you know there were some early onsets
of something more going on that's why
what you're doing mark is really
important by really having people having
that awareness factor put out into the
public so that other people watching
this video
might be able to detect things so early
on
and then you know of course amanda like
a lot of people started hanging out with
the wrong crowd
she started off with abusing marijuana
and i know a lot of people say marijuana
is very harmless but
if you have a dissociative disorder or
if possible schizophrenia it can
actually make those things a lot worse
so no drug is safe in my opinion
it's not just safe to just experiment
everybody should be really careful with
their brains
but yeah so she she started to hang out
with the wrong crowd and
she started to use marijuana she began
to get more paranoid
and then it just escalated from other
drugs from there and that's how
we ended up with a crack addiction and
being homeless
her father has tried to get her housing
multiple times
and every time she's been evicted
and it hasn't worked out and like i said
it's not a housing issue
when you have such a severe mental
illness it's
really um about getting treatment and
getting proper care
lima thank you for for everything you're
doing for
for amanda and maybe others and we'll
see how it goes
will i be able to do like updates with
amanda absolutely so we're going to be
doing updates with amanda
and um i know that i haven't done enough
already
we're getting we're going to be doing
really positive updates with amanda
we're going to be documenting step by
step exactly how
you know she's she's benefiting in
exactly the path that we're taking with
her treatment
so that other people can can take that
model and apply it to their situations
excellent okay cool well thank you so
much for everything and thank you
these will be exciting updates
absolutely i'm very excited and
thank you guys all everybody that's
watching for all of your support and all
the positive feedback i really
appreciate it
thank you